what's going on there reject nation we
are going to start up today all of us
are dead the new korean zombie netflix
series i don't know yet what our upload
schedule is going to be like when the
next episode comes out which i'm hoping
that we get this up every other day i'll
have something much more clear and
precise i'm going to expect these
reactions to go up consistently but yeah
i mean we just finished watching the
kingdom finale that'll go up this
weekend now we're moving on to another
korean zombie show
why not right loving loving the theme
here i see this being talked about a lot
we even put out a community post but
this was worth covering and then
actually a lot of people were like skip
it and then when i was going through
comments i was realizing a lot of people
who were voting skip it i haven't even
watched the show so i was like okay
there's something else this community
post is not reliable at all
yeah but we're interested so we figured
why not let's check it out uh if you can
go ahead and hit that like button that
would be very much appreciated also
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next all of us are dead is up as
always full length watch alongs where
you sync up with the time code for any
show we cover is over at our patreon
page thanks to all of become superjects
by checking out all we got to offer over
there and the boys over prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
let's get to it people
emergency cross jesus
damn this guy's relentless a very
convincing fight
get him
[Music]
[Applause]
interesting so what's this
transformation process like
nothing a little jesus can't fix
oh my god
can a bible crush someone's head
that kind of book
that's a pretty flexible bible or is
just symbolic [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god did he infect his kid with
that in order to defend himself maybe
get out of there man
[Music]
oh it's gonna be fun
that's a great dissolved
[Music]
getting to know the layout of where all
the actions are going to take place
oh they'll be able to defend themselves
man i want to learn how to do archery
dead frog photo scorpion metaphor
[Laughter]
symbolism in every frame
[Music]
it's gonna be like a rat or something
oh
what's gonna happen to this little guy
i don't know where this is headed he's
gonna start an outbreak
god
oh no
god damn rat back up yeah put that metal
thing back on oh he was responsible
foreign
oh no he's figuring some [ __ ] out
he's writing in english collected
parasitic
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
like none of these kids get to class on
time
none of the kids are eating breakfast
i'm all rushing
i'm gonna go to school
[Laughter]
green light
so they're all trained runners
[Music]
what a messed up school
oh
no no no no
what the [ __ ]
no come on carl
that's the weird part
[Music]
oh it's messed up man
oh come on guys
and were those two you passed earlier
the only two adults at the school
[Music]
take your benzo
what's this guy's goal
i don't know
is this an accident or is this part of
the plan
which is
[Music]
he should not do jack [ __ ] about that
what's going on
that radiator is coming off
oh oh no
she's got to be making some noise right
that could alert people
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Laughter]
is she having a period
oh no please
holy balls
or she's just infected and i just jumped
up here
that's what i did
cramps
or did you call the police about the
science teacher you had some pretty big
accusations coming out of her mouth
i've got to let him finish class first
she went
no
no they can't fall in love
what
stop the spread of it well there's a
whole classroom of people who tell you
people who've been talking about it
i got you some socks
[Music]
oh man that zombie's just gonna want to
make it right back to school
oh
no
so annoying
oh god
oh my god was that his bully
what the [ __ ]
oh my god
[Music]
oh
man
yeah that's not good
[Music]
no
god
cut that arm off
why is it happening so faster maybe it
happens faster to adults
[Music]
does this train to bassan movie exist in
this universe
does anybody know this issue how this
works
[Laughter]
i mean when shoot really hits the fan
some of these characters have to have
seen a zombie movie
with great power
oh i hope you guys are the first yeah
rip them apart
use their faces
get him
[Applause]
nice
it begins and now let's get someone over
here to film you
cool
wow that was fast that's much faster
[Music]
no
no
school
this is why you should get homeschooled
oh no
[Music]
no
no one notices her standing there
internet
that's why
oh my god dude just just say yes
loud and proud
there's still pedal
what's wrong
let's go think those guys are on the
roof man yeah
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man
oh
ugh
[Music]
it's real like
psychedelic percolating build to that's
those tunes man yeah
because she's been bit too oh maybe
maybe he smells it or maybe he just
needed to get a second to be like
hear me roar for a guy that likes where
comes in it
hits him up yeah
yeah he needs to open up that
opportunity for him to be a hero that
was neat it was very neat and that was
neat
i didn't expect such a teen drama show
so it's very teen drama
with uh
the discussion of bullying in school i
don't know what schools are like in
korea no no idea
what it's like
so sometimes i'm like is that how things
go okay maybe you know yeah
but in terms of what we're getting i
think it's i'm interested to see how it
all ultimately coalesces together
because sometimes the
rhythm can be a tad off to me
where like some of the horror can feel
like sporadic yeah and then like oh
we're really slowing down a lot now yeah
and but the thing is on the flip side i
really like that because that's why i
just want to see how it ultimately
unfolds because
um the i like that you're really taking
the time to build the dynamics build the
relationships
build the chemistry with a bunch of
these people at school like you're not
you're seeing the faculty
faculty
the faculty
you're seeing yeah all the students and
such and um and then of course there's a
lot of themes uh and allegories dealing
with like watched allegories it's just
very it's it's very heavy-handed uh the
whole thing with bullying going on in
the school as well
and uh
so i wanna more than just seeing like i
hope this bullet gets taken down i i
wanna see how the themes is they treat
it with such heavy subject matter like
you have that one student who's straight
up being like you know sexually
assaulted and then she's willing to
commit suicide by the end like these are
these are very heavy topics
and um i don't know maybe she'll find
something to live for by the end
but she'll become a badass zombie killer
yeah yeah validation through there
because you have like a very serious
subject matter you're exploring
and then on the
opposite spectrum there's almost this
like
level of camp with the zombie stuff you
know yeah it's it it feels like very
like like i said earlier the music has
this like psychedelic influence to it
it's like boom boom boom boom like this
build yeah like this percussion build
reminded some of the music cues in like
a 28 days later or something like that
yeah yeah but it's more uh when it comes
to the zombie stuff it it it feels like
a lot more sci-fi infused
and like they they get like real trippy
with it shots so some some like looking
forward to seeing how the marriage of
all these elements comes together if it
if it ultimately does
because yeah it's like sometimes the the
rhythm can feel a little bit off to me
because i like i really like i i always
want my horror to do the character
building and do the relationship stuff
and i think because of the fact that
it's a zombie show we know that zombies
are coming and he had the anxiety of
like [ __ ] guys zombies you know and then
it's like oh the anxiety is built okay
now we're cutting to hang out with these
people here yeah yeah yeah and uh but by
the end of it you know it is it is
pretty exciting stuff so i am curious to
see how how ultimately the pace unfolds
but yeah what'd you think of the
for first episode it's pretty solid it's
a saw pilot i'm definitely interested to
see how it goes yeah i really enjoyed it
i think that was the sort of most unique
thing here was the way that they
presented
the story with all the different scenes
and the juxtaposition of yeah what's a
normal day like for all these people
versus the outbreak that's about to turn
everything upside down and i agree i i
feel like i'm going to need a minute to
let it sort of matriculate through my
brain in terms of how it feels as an
overall pacing experience but i do
appreciate that geography of like okay
this thing is breaking out while
everything's you know normal in various
other pockets of the school and i feel
like that gives it an interesting you
know like
every zombie movie seeks to put you
there in the action but i feel like that
is a kind of interesting way to do it
that doesn't really feel like any other
zombie movie or show i have seen up
until this point uh because you know you
start out in a pretty intense place of
just character anguish and then
immediately you're also given this piece
of context where it has something to do
or it's coinciding with the start of
this outbreak that has
some originating connective tissue to
the you know science teacher the bio
teacher
and then you know seeing how those two
things really stay parallel even across
all the moments like for so it's
interesting like the characters
and i feel like this is a good thing
because it is kind of real
it's like there's nobody who seems just
like oh they're the good guy or
protagonist character of the show right
now like everyone's
you know they're all kids they're all a
bit rascally and stuff like that you
know they're all just kind of of a
normal day of school and so i feel like
that's an exciting thing too is maybe
there will be some coming of age and
some real sort of character revealing
through these kids as they undergo this
horrific nightmare experience
and uh it was like sarcastic ribbing but
i would say like the mate the first the
guy with the the neighbor
i think he's like a good i think he's
like they just sarcastically rip each
other yeah i don't think there's or like
they jest but i don't think there's any
like if there are a lot of characters
just kind of mean
yeah yeah totally and between the two of
them i i do appreciate yeah it's like
the two of them and maybe the other guy
who she's crushing on and stuff like
that you know that's a former betty yeah
that'll become a
love triangle or something yeah
uh but yeah you know like yeah the way
that they do have that sort of
you know sibling-esque ribbing like i
like that approach to the character for
some reason these didn't feel quite as
and this isn't even coming from
hollywood so i don't want to use the
word like holly woody but you know like
they didn't feel like movie characters
so much as they felt like yeah you're
just kind of in a school and everybody's
you know doing the same run-of-the-mill
stuff that they're always doing and this
is kind of how they have their rapport
together
and so yeah there's sort of uh
i don't know exactly what the right word
is but i like the way they drew the
characters alongside you know the chaos
that's breaking loose true i think the
way it's shot too when it comes to the
zombie moments are really cool they use
a lot of these one takes oh yeah it's
like for the most part steady cam it's
really steady like the first shot has
this really good opener
and that really establishes your mood
and your theme of it like it starts off
on the like emergency red cross and it
seems like there's gonna be some
biblical allegories as well
flat out beats his son with a bible
yeah and he's the saves with the shot of
it circling in it and i i do and then of
course like the the ending uh towards
the end too when the camera is moving
soon enough from the school like you
have this
interesting set of where like they're
getting you acquainted with like here's
the layout
of the sets yeah where chaos can ensue
and i like i like a lot of the shots
that they use here and they're very very
clear and they don't rely heavily on
like some shots are very like the
chaotic jittery [ __ ] that we often
associate with fast-running zombies now
yeah
but that it's not overly reliant on that
which i i think is impressive um
and it does have a quirkiness about it
yes which was something i wasn't i i
don't i didn't see a trailer for this so
i don't know anything about it i'd like
to walk into this go wow this is pretty
uh it's pretty different than what i
agree when i hear like korean zombie
show but but it has that like soap opera
korean you know what it is
i think of what why
that rhythm could feel a little bit off
is because we're still getting to while
i find the characters interesting and
we're still getting to know the
characters
the zombie stuff is the most familiar
and the thing you're probably looking
forward to most when hearing about this
show so my high level of interest tends
to be in the zombie stuff yeah so i'm
like super invested and interested
whenever there's like crazy song and
then it cuts to the other stuff and i
think like so maybe it's not even a
pacing problem but it's more of um or i
don't know actually but
in the moment it's like but i'm way more
interested right now with that zombie
thing than i am and hearing them like
talk about their crushes right yeah
yeah yeah is the chicken good
yeah you build it up i think too it goes
against formula in a lot of ways with
how they cut around
because usually it would be like you you
get the characters a queen and dotted
dawn and then like the last 20 minutes
then the outbreak starts
we're crazy for just 23 minutes as
opposed to
stop yeah it's like you introduce them
side by side and you let the outbreak be
building from the beginning true true
yeah but it's a good show uh so far
right now what we're getting is good
yeah i don't know what this i'm still
still curious to know like what the
split was on like community posts as if
it was
if that had to do with
the
looking at the comments i was like yeah
i'm like is it actually the other side
is it the fact that people don't really
like the show or was it the comments
that i saw of like people who didn't
actually watch it mm-hmm like i just hit
no because
i just said because i want i have
another show i want you to start up this
one yeah yeah
not this
yeah for sure um
but yeah it's cool it's cool stuff it's
cool stuff still got eleven more
episodes to go got one little context
clue just a quick shout out to gwenever
call over at the patreon who said you
know that that partly what they're gonna
dig on at least in terms of
like the overall there's there's a ferry
accidents the seawall ferry accident
that brought up a bunch of you know uh
questions in
korea and whatnot about you know the
sort of culture of obedience and that
was something that i thought was sort of
starting to uh
you know show its head with the adult
characters and if there's one thing i
would guess it's that probably because
they're all like the adults throughout
this episode are constantly sitting
around like we should have dealt with
this internally well don't call the
police well we gotta
yeah so like i feel like probably the
one thing i would imagine they'll start
to examine with the adult characters
would be yeah how do we
approach the spread of information and
the spread of protocols that our society
puts out versus actually addressing a
crisis for what it is you know
yeah yeah but uh yeah interesting about
the only clues thanks for that gwenevere
thanks gwenevere it's a cool clue to
have yeah
all right guys we'll keep a lookout for
one in reaction to the next episode is
up i'll try to get up in a couple days
that's why you guys subscribe and stay
notified look out for that notification
bell ignore the ones that you're not
interested in and then click on the ones
you're interested in that's how it works
yeah selection process use your judgment
all right guys we will talk to you soon
[Music]